[Music]
each and every day we all take partner
normal daily rituals such as eating
breathing and brushing our teeth
engaging in these actions becomes second
nature and we start to do them without
even thinking but would you be surprised
if we told you that you've been doing
many of your normal daily functions
totally wrong if this is your first time
visiting our channel don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up because today we're
sharing 10 everyday things we've been
doing wrong your entire life microwaving
leftover there's a reason why your food
is always cold in the center after you
remove it from the microwave thinking
inside microwave heats up the food on
the edge of your plate first and by the
time the buzzer rings the food in the
center of your plate is usually a bit
cold
to avoid this all you have to do is
spread your food out on your plate so
that it circles around the outer edge
with the food easily distributed around
the corners of the plate it will all
feed us evenly and whole booth will be a
single pack
Lynette the themes needing chicken wings
when a plated chicken wings is placed in
front of you it's hard not to grab a few
and put seeds again but believe it or
not the way you've been devouring the
dish is completely wrong the correct way
to eat chicken wings is to grab the two
bones twist them and then slowly pull
the bones out when you're done you'll be
left to feast on the delicious chicken
without the bones getting in your way
brushing your teeth we learn how to
brush our teeth very early on in our
lives but many of us are brushing our
pearly whites incorrectly aggression
with a hard toothbrush will wear down
your enamel tank and hurt your gum so
fix is soft and medium bristle you said
then instead of moving the brush from
side to side you should float the
toothbrush at a 45-degree angle and use
short up and down stroke brushing your
teeth and gums in this motion is the
best way to remove plaque and other yoga
listening to music on your phone playing
music on your phone and maximizing the
sound just got a whole lot easier all
you have to do is place your phone
inside a glass or ceramic cups to
enhance the decibels and it will really
pump up the volume you can make your own
DIY count then using all sorts of
household items aside from cups you can
place your phone in a bowl or you can
create a make
pastin piece of cardboards fixing the
water damage cellphone one of the worst
things that can possibly happen is when
you draw through cell phone in the
toilet organs in the middle of a
swimming pool we've been told to stash a
water damage phone into a bag of rice to
prepare it but there's actually a better
way to fix it they left a ziploc bag
with silica gel packets and saved your
phone inside after a few days the silica
will absorb moisture from the phone to
bring a fast indict peeling a banana
your entire life you've probably been
peeling bananas the wrong way most of us
have been prosecuted banana from the
tops but this can be difficult and it
actually takes much longer than
necessary the peel bananas the correct
way all we have to do to seem a little
bit of guidance from monkeys and other
primates they open the banana from the
bottom and the peel falls off like magic
if you don't believe us just give it a
try and find out for yourself oh yes
don't forget to thank us later freezing
if you're watching this video there's a
pretty good chance you're alive and
breathing in some glorious air but we're
pretty sure the way you're breathing
isn't the correct way there's actually a
proper way to breathe and includes
breathing from your abdominals instead
of breathing from your chest taking in
air from your chest will result in
shallow breaths anxiety sweaty palms and
less oxygen in case breaking in moon
shoes when you buy a new pair of shoes
the first thing you probably do is clip
them on and walk around in them for a
few minutes for cement breaking in a new
pair of shoes can take more than a few
days for the material become more
flexible but the easiest way to get your
new shoes nice and loose as quickly as
possible is to throw on a pair of thick
socks put your shoes on your feet and
use a hair dryer to blow hot air on the
tight corners of the shoes keep
repeating the process until your shoe
fits comfortably sitting down after a
long day at school or worse this
probably can't wait to go home and plop
down on the couch until it's time for
you to go to bed and start your day all
over again but the ax is sitting down
and not normal at all studies have shown
that our body's one designed to sit down
for long periods of time they were
actually made to remain in constant
motion the lack of activity in spending
more than 10 hours sitting down each day
can lead to heart disease diabetes and
other
help shoot scooping when nature calls
you run to the bathroom and sit on the
toilet to go number two you probably
haven't put too much thought into the
position of your body while you're
sitting on the toilet seat right well
guess what the way most of us fit on the
throne is all wrong medical research has
proven that squatting on the toilet is
more effective because the prescience
resides up against the stomach the angle
of the body acts as a natural laxative
to move your poops in your bowels at
lightning speed those who squat can take
a poop in an average of 51 seconds while
those who keep sitting down take about
one hundred and thirty seconds in total
so go ahead and get your squat on the
next time you get the urge to take a
poop
did we just completely shock you with
our list of everyday things you've been
doing wrong pages a comment down below
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up
[Music]